taking care of parameters you don't have
to with prandtls
my name is hank and i work on compute
studio which is a website for
publishing and running computational
models data visualizations
also on the leadership council of the
policy simulation library
which is a home for open source public
policy models
hello pi data param tools is a parameter
processing library
thanks for having me now let's learn
more about print tools
gram tools helps you document your
model's inputs
and validate your user's inputs it's
built on top of marshmallow which gives
it a nice foundation
and it makes it easy to extend print
tools and add custom data types
but more broadly ram tools is a way to
share your models with others
who's using cram tools matchups this is
a little app that i made that's not
compute studio
and you can analyze pitching and batting
matchups for
interleave baseball players pi
21 is a project one of my friends made
and you can
analyze different strategies for
blackjack
and pram tools is used under the hood to
parameterize the rules of blackjack so
you
can see how your strategies work out
under different
game scenarios tax cruncher
this is a model in the
policy simulation library and this is
just showing
how how text printer reads in
pram tools inputs from json files
so why program tools the policy
simulation library
has a bunch of tax models in it and they
directly depend on each other
and they're all mostly focused on the
u.s tax code
so that means their inputs are very
complicated because that's
just how the us tax code is and one of
the models
tax credit glitter had a really nice
parameter processing back end
and other models and psl
really liked it and they liked it so
much that they
they took how timescaler approached this
problem and they used that for their
projects too and by that i mean they
copied and pasted this parameters class
into their their repositories and then
they modified it so that it would work
for their projects this was a really
nice solution
and then general pattern was working
really well for a lot of different
projects
but in the end the maintainers of these
projects wanted to focus
on the things that they were modeling
and they don't want to have to maintain
an 800
to 1000 line long module that's not
doing anything that's directly related
to
their model
[Music]
so i saw an opportunity to make a new
package
that could do this heavy lifting for the
models and that's when pram tools was
created
grand tools provides a standard format
for model inputs it's based on
the format the tax calculator uses
and i tried to make this format general
enough to work for
for all kinds of models not just once in
psl
but but beyond um it validates
inputs it makes parameter values
available as numpy arrays this makes it
easy to integrate with the rest of the
pi data ecosystem
and at the same time as i was putting
parent tools i was also building compute
studio
and i wanted to build something that
would that would make it easy to build
web interfaces for
python models and cram tools fit that
mold because it was able to
communicate over different processes
just using
normal json
so now we're going to hop over to a demo
and we're just going to
build a really simple attack calculator
and this is going to help demonstrate
some cram tools concepts and i think in
an
interesting way especially in light of
all the tax talk that we're going to do
throughout this so here we have a really
simple
tax equation the tax you owe to the
government is just the tax rate
multiplied by
income and so to get started with our
model we're going to import param tools
and create a taxes class
this taxes class subclass is the pram
tools parameters class
and it has one class attribute the
defaults
and this is just a dictionary with the
parameters you go into our model in this
case
just tax rate and this tax rate has a
title
you know tax rate uh it has a
description the percentage of income
that goes to the man
and the data type is a float
the default value is 10 and
the it has some validators just one
the the range and minimum value of zero
maximum value of one that makes sense
it's just a simple rate there are other
validators like
my choice so the user has to input a
value that's one of a discrete set of
choices
or you can also have different data
types you could have
an integer or string or a date
this this class just has one method it
uses it implements this equation that we
defined above where we're grabbing the
tax rate
and getting to the value and multiplying
that by the income that the user passes
in
so we create our taxes class we create
our taxes
object we calculate our taxes for
someone who's making
fifty thousand dollars a year and so
that person is paying five thousand
dollars in taxes
uh so that's ten percent of fifty 000 so
that makes sense
we have these validation rules what
happens if we break them
let's pass in a negative value and see
what happens
we get a validation error that's exactly
what we were hoping for
so the tax rate is negative 0.1 and
that's less than
uh the minimum value of zero
one thing about taxes is that they tend
to change over time
so let's make sure we can handle updates
to our tax model so suppose
the government wants to raise taxes in
2021 to 15 percent of income
in order to model this uh correctly we
need to add some information
about what year it is because if we
don't have this year information
then we would just wipe out the the
prior tax rate we could
be harder to compare what our what taxes
we're paying in one year to the taxes
from paying another year
so we do that by creating the schema
object
and it has a labels object in it
and this just it just this contains one
year label and it's the type is an
integer
it has a range validator the minimum
value is 20 20 and the maximum value is
20 30.
and our new default value
just says the tax rate takes effect in
2020 and the value is 0.1
and then the run method is updated so
that we're getting the right tax rate
for the year that the user is passing in
so we create our new taxes class our new
taxes object we're going to
do the same calculation as before but
we're going to specify what year
we want to calculate our taxes in so
we're doing fifty thousand dollars in
2020 that's the answer we're looking for
we're going to calculate our taxes or
we're going to
update the tax rules for 2021 to
the tax proposal that we presented up
here so we're going to raise taxes to 15
and we're going to take a look at tax
rate and so the new value
is 15 percent in year 2021
and parentals knows to do that because
you passed in the list
but the dictionary and the label uh
year wasn't isn't in the default values
and so
this this new value is just tacked on to
our uh parameter values
and when we run our taxes our tax model
for year 2021 with our 50 000
income we get 7 500 so that
works looks good to me and
next we need to make sure that we can
calculate taxes for multiple years
this is helpful if you want to look
ahead and see how our taxes are going to
change in the future
so we could add a run all method like
this this is kind of cumbersome
on the other hand we could just do this
with numpy arrays because we all we
really want to do is take an array of
tax rates and multiply that by
some value of income that we're passing
in and pram tools has really good
support for
numpy arrays and all you have to do to
tell fram tools
that we want to work with numpy arrays
is add this operators
object and it has one member array first
you set that to true
and then parentals will try to convert
your parameter values into numpy arrays
and
we're going to update our default values
for the text rate
so that we have a tax rate for all the
years
in our in our 10-year window
and then we update our run all method so
that we're back to just multiplying the
tax rate
times the income that's passed in by the
user
and we take a look at our our new taxes
object
and our tax rate values and it's a numpy
array we can work with it just like all
numpy arrays
um we calculate taxes for our window
and it's five thousand dollars for all
ten years and that makes sense because
our income
is fifty thousand for all ten years and
our the tax rate is ten percent
so we have our uh our government's plan
to increase taxes to 15
so we're gonna do that right here and
um we expected
the effects to be permanent but the they
really
according to this the government's tax
plan only goes into effect for 2021
and so we need to update our adjust
method
so that the tax rate is updated for all
years in our budget window
and we do that just by looping over the
years from 2020 to 2021 to 20 30.
let me take a look at the tax rate and
it's updated correctly
so we're in business our tax models
working
just like we were hoping all right
so now that we've built a simple tax
calculator
let's talk about the tax calculator this
is the real deal
and it takes on all the complexity of
the
you know individual income uh tax code
and and tax regulator is
it's used by presidential campaigns uh
the legislative and executive branches
in the u.s
um it's a serious model used by serious
people
um and when i created pram tools one of
my goals
at some point was to get pam tools and
tax calculator working
uh well together when print tools was
created
i wanted it to be general enough to work
with a lot of different kinds of models
but it was always helpful for me to
look at tax calcula tax calculator and
thing
okay this works for a lot of different
kinds of models but does it still work
for something as
complicated as tax calculator that was
just a nice
a nice guide for me as i was developing
parentals
and so over the past couple years i've
you know kept up with this project you
know keeping task calculator and fan
tools close together
and trying to think about how they could
be integrated
one day and one thing that you should
know is that tax law is really
complicated
as i've been saying and i
i really had to dig into it and learn
how to update different uh parameters to
get this all to work
um and even beyond tax law
this is just a general software design
challenge
uh tax calculator is complicated um it's
been
around for you know five or seven years
um
there are a lot of notebooks laying
around that have done policy analyses
with tax calculator
so i don't want to come through and try
to swap something out tax calculator
and have a break you know people's
notebooks from years ago
tax calculator also has a really
sophisticated
and thorough test suite and so i need to
be careful
that uh to be good to that test suite
and to take care of it if i'm
ever going to try to really fully
integrate principles and tax translator
um so as i went along this process and
thought about
getting tax cycling and prime tools to
work together i
really tried to keep an eye on how i
could
work with tax circuiters test suite so
that i could add new code without
modifying tests
uh at least only the the most minimal
amount of changes to existing tests
and i wanted to make sure i could add
new tests to
and then also the parameters class
uh that existed before uh
tax decline and printful started working
together um
was tough was tough to read there's a
lot of low-level
code that that you that you had to parse
through
in order to understand exactly what was
going on
with how data was being written or
updated so i wanted
to replace that with some higher level
instructions and just make it
a little easier for for more people to
work on
and so i set about working on this
project and really it
unfolded in four stages over maybe a
year and a half to two years
and you know at the very beginning i
just wanted to know
can i load the tax calculator defaults
file and then
i um and then i did a toy implementation
um just to kind of see how close ram
tools was to working with tax calculator
and get some feedback from the community
and then i did a third party package
that could be used for tax calculator
and uh i got a lot of good feedback from
that i learned a lot about how text
regulators
uh internal logic works and then i
eventually did full integration open pr
to tax calculator and saw that all the
way through
um so very beginning i was
working on tax calculators uh
default inputs and working with the
print tools version of them
to make sure that pram tools could
handle tax calculator concepts
and that i had defined a standard format
that was flexible enough to still work
with tensor glitter and handle
the complexities that has
and then i also focused early on on
making sure that the parameter values
were accessible as numpy arrays
and this is just really important in the
python ecosystem
so that you're interoperable with all
the the great tools
in it and then once that was working and
printful's just getting some adoption
i circled back and did a toy
implementation with tax calculators
indexing logic
and that hangs out in this notebook here
and i
kind of wrote it up as a blog post i
added different levels of
different layers of
features to to make this all work and i
did it all in a very
custom and specific manner
and at the end of the the notebook
i um i was able to
do an adjustment with a pram tool style
inputs and a tax calculator style of
inputs
and i was able to compare that the
values were the same
and and that was a big deal to me just
to get everything to match up
and see that okay print tools is a
serious project
and they can handle this like this
pretty tough uh
this tough logic and uh that the task
declutter implements but what i wound up
is
is is with this this index parameters
class
and when i showed this notebook to tax
calculator developers and other people
in
psl i said hey guys look what i've made
what do you think and should i just go
ahead and open up a pr to tax calculator
and they're kind of like whoa
not so fast this is still pretty
complicated we already have our own
complicated code
we don't really need your complicated
code but it would be cool
if gram tools could just do all this
stuff in a general way and just
supported this out of the box
and then it would be worth it for tax
calculator to start thinking about using
program tools
and so i realized i needed two new
features i needed to be able to extend
values over multiple years
and i needed to be able to index these
values to inflation
and head back over to our notebook i'm
going to show you
how these two features work in program
tools
and now that they now that they're in
the project
and i think you'll see how how uh
how much power they give to the premium
tools and how much you're able to do
with them
uh so in our previous example we updated
the value in 2021 in this
this array example and it wasn't carried
through for future years
which is kind of frustrating and we also
had to define
all these values here for for all the
years in our window even though the
value of the parameter isn't changing
it's still 0.1
[Music]
so in this multi-year taxes class we're
going to
do this a little bit more concisely and
it's going to
it's gonna have more functionality and
all we need to add
is this label to extend member of the
operators object and we're gonna say
we want the the parameter values to be
extended
using the year label and printfulness
you can look at
the year label and see it's type integer
it has a range from min
2020 to max 2030 and by default where
parentals assumes this uh that
the the values from 2020 to 2030 are
going up by one
so it's going to take on values from
2020 2021 2022 and so on
but you there you you can you can modify
this so it increases by two or three or
uh some other uh step besides just one
a run all method is the same um
this is we're back to just having a list
with one
value a dictionary with the year 2020
value 0.1
create our multi-year taxes we do our
update check our tax rate
[Music]
oh we need to create our multi-year
taxes class
our new one and now we do that and
we get our perfect uh we get the the
value
set in 2021 to 15 and then
for the rest of the years in the window
it's still 15 but we have this auto
attribute which is important for
internal
ram tools uh logic uh but you could also
use it if you want to add your own
custom
extend logic um we calculate our taxes
for the 10-year window and we get 5000
and 7 500 for the rest
so it's working like we're hoping and um
and this is pretty powerful uh so this
is very concise
um the values are extended in a simple
intuitive way
uh we're really getting somewhere and so
the next concept that needed that
parentals needed to support
is once it could extend values along
multiple years
is we needed to have logic for how those
values should be extended
and by default gram tools handles
indexing so you can grow parameter
values according to some rate
and and so
this models the case where a parameter
value is growing according to
inflation and so you can index a value
to inflation
and we're going to add a new parameter
to just to demonstrate this
it's a deduction parameter and all it is
is we're saying we're going to take our
income we're going to subtract out the
deduction
then we're going to multiply that
adjusted amount by the tax rate
that'll be our taxes owed and
so first let's talk about our deduction
parameter
it's just the amount you deduct from
your income
it's a float parameter it's indexed it
has a default value in 2020 and
it the minimum value can take on is zero
and we update our operators
object to say that we are using an
extend function
and that just means that frame tools is
going to
call a method called extend func
and that's going to return the next
value uh you know as the print as grant
tools is extending the values for
parameter we have our index rates and
parentals we'll use this
by default to extend values for multiple
years
we have a new method for adjusting our
income for inflation because that's
going
to be affected in addition to the
deduction parameter
and we create our index taxes class
new taxes object check out our deduction
it's growing
according to the inflation rates and we
run our taxes for 10 years and we can
see that they're
going up a little bit every year just
due to inflation
so this this is a pretty
sophisticated uh model given that it's
only
you know 50 lines of code and a lot of
it is just
you know basically a dictionary
specifying
how uh how the input should be modeled
and now we're going to hop back into our
our journey for getting tax check
glitter and gram tools working together
and see
how these features uh kind of brought
cram tools the rest of the way to being
able to
work with to work with tax calculator in
a serious way
so the next step was tax frames and
opening a pr on tax calculator seemed
like it was going to be hard
there's a lot of extra stuff there it'd
be hard to test everything
be really hard to figure out if i'm
implementing
all the indexing and update rules
correctly
and so i just did it in isolation and
also made it easy because i could
compare values on the text graham's
object
with values on that attachment letter
object to make sure i was doing
everything correctly
and i didn't have to worry about all
kinds of other tests really
and uh and i could pass this to a
calculator
object and you know calculate uh the
effects of some
uh tax reform using the the
pram tool style update and
uh that the difference is carried
through there the result the calculator
ran there were no errors
this was this was a big deal for me it
made me really excited to
see everything run and there to be
differences in this table
meaning that the the parameters were
updated and
everything went through that tax
regulator model like it was supposed to
um and so i shared this with my friends
in the tax calculator community and psl
you know broadly and i asked for
feedback and people were impressed
they thought this was a nice project um
i'd even documented the algorithm for
the tax calculator used to
update parameters which was uh not
documented very well
and the texture for their project and so
i gave back a little bit
the text calculator there
i found a weird indexing
bug it was like way way edge case that
probably would never be hit otherwise
but
i couldn't figure out why the values
were matching the tax grams
to the values and tax regulator and one
of there was a bug and tax calculator
that i found that way
and so so there was mutual benefits all
around and
tax calculator suggested the tax
reporter team suggested that i open the
pr
and see if i can just get this merch in
the tax calculator
that way it can really fully be reviewed
before it's used by anyone else
you know either in the in the tax
declared ecosystem or someone who's just
stumbling along the project uh
we don't want someone to do some
analysis it's uh
and then there'll be a bug because this
wasn't reviewed correctly
and so a few months later i started
working on this
work in progress pr for tax cut litter
to use
gram tools and took maybe a month or two
just kind of working on this when when i
had time and energy
you know i would get you know one
section of the test to pass and move to
another section of the test
i'd circle back i would document i was
always kind of cleaning things up and
trying to get
uh the next portion of the test to pass
but eventually all the tests passed
and i opened a pr and and i
worked
with the tax calculator team to get it
merged you know over two months
there were 67 comments
but eventually it got in and um
it's it's uh easier to to work with now
the parameters classes
uh a week or two after this pr was
merged
someone else opened a pr that modified
the parameters class
that and this modification fixed a
long-standing bug and then
uh tax calculator indexing logic that
would have been hard to fix
if if tax calculator wasn't using cram
tools
and so that someone else was already
able to come through and modify the code
and improve
uh tax calculator that was a huge win
that just means that it was a little bit
more readable and
people were understanding what was going
on a little bit better um
so what did i learn from this i learned
that it's important to work in the open
and share your results and just get
feedback um
if you're if i'd worked on this by
myself you know for two years
it i i might have gotten done and i
could have uh asked people hey what do
you think about this project that would
have been like oh we actually like what
we have sorry
and i would have been you know that
would have been a lot of work that i
missed um
and then also um you should experiment
and
prototype uh don't just go for
the perfect solution right off the bat
just try to get something to work
and try to learn from that first
implementation and then
try to you know come up with better and
better solutions after that
finally just spread out your effort
especially for an open source project
that you're doing on the side
make sure you take breaks maybe work on
other projects too when you have time
just do it when you have energy uh that
that was that was really helpful
for me um and here now that we've talked
about taxes for
you know 20 minutes let's think through
a couple other potential use cases
maybe you can model the spread of code
and use a gram print tools parameters
class in the back end
uh maybe you have some parameters for
social distancing level
or a flag for mandatory mass
do you allow indoor restaurants and so
on
you could have the parentals in a
business analytics pipeline
um your parameters for your model could
be you know number of new users number
new trials revenue from subscriptions
um you know and more things like that
that you could then
feed into your analytics model
[Music]
so what's coming up next for gram tools
i
want to just generally improve the
documentation both for pram tools and
for
models that are using gram tools um
i want to try to integrate with
other parts of the pi data ecosystem
like bokeh
it'd be great if you could take a
prandtl's parameter
and then there'd be like a function or
method where
that would return a bokeh widget that
you could just embed in a chart
i think better integration with tools
like pandas
where where you could go from a
parameters class to a panda's data frame
and then back uh you know doing doing
those
those conversions i think a typescript
implementation would be really nice for
parentals
uh that i've done something like this
for compute studio
but i would like to build a standalone
version
so that other people can more easily
work on it and develop
client-side applications
but uh but that's that's what's on my
mind and kind of where cram tools is
going but
i'm can't wait to hear feedback from
people who
watch this talk and uh thank you for
uh for listening and looking forward to
speaking with you
on the panel